[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend nach bayern und sachsen
zieht jetzt baden württemberg nach und
verhängt auch schärfere corona maßnahmen
für landkreise mit besonders hohem
instanzen so gibt es unter anderem
nächtliche ausgangssperren für
ungeimpfte die zudem nicht mehr in
gastronomie oder einzelhandel dürfen
abgesehen von lebensnotwendigen wie
lebensmittelläden oder apotheken die
länder versuchen jetzt noch mit
maßnahmen gegenzusteuern für die ab
donnerstag die rechtsgrundlage fehlen
wird bereits verhängte beschränkungen
wie etwa ausgangssperren dürfen dann
noch bis mitte dezember fortgeführt
werden und man ahnt wo wir pandemisch
bis dahin stehen werden dazu später in
der sendung noch ein gespräch mit rk ii
chef lothar lila doch zunächst berichtet
dort ferber wie höchst unterschiedlich
und unberechenbar hierzulande wieder
einmal entschieden wird je nachdem wo
man sich gerade befindet beispiel
weihnachtsmarkt
genießen oder geimpft auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt am düsseldorfer rathaus
wird streng kontrolliert
ab morgen sollen dann zwei bändchen
verteilt werden die meisten finden das
in ordnung ich meine mama mitgerechnet
darum alles mit uns ist so wie es ist
und wenn es nötig ist manchmal zweig
regelung finde ich erfolg kommen fallen
damit also
ich glaube wir müssen alle damit jetzt
irgendwie umgehen lernen umgehen zu
können
2g erreicht nicht allen veranstalterin
anke peters hat ihre weihnachtsmärkte an
den adventswochenenden abgesagt schloss
grünewald kloster eberbach sie hätten
stattfinden dürfen aber tausende
menschen dicht gedrängt dass er das
infektionsrisiko einfach zu hoch
wir wollten einfach selber die
verantwortung übernehmen ich denke mal
das was jetzt beschlossen wurde reicht
nicht aus und was dann das heißt es wird
nachgebessert im dezember das ist alles
viel zu spät wir müssen jetzt reagieren
wir müssen jetzt die kontakte
einschränken und ich gehe fest davon aus
dass auch weitere restriktionen kommen
kein weihnachtsmarkt kein umsatz für die
schmuckdesignerin hätten die
adventswochenenden die hälfte ihre
jahreseinnahmen bedeutet die ware ist
nun schon da das verständnis aber auch
das war erstmal totaler schock also ich
habe damit nicht wirklich gerechnet
dieses jahr wieder dass das wieder
passiert aber eigentlich wenn man sich
die zahlen so ein bisschen überlegt hat
und angeguckt hat ist das eigentlich die
richtige entscheidung hilfe für
betroffene aussteller gibt es bislang
nicht auch die händler des dresdner
striezelmarktes stehen vor dem nichts
der berühmte markt kurz vor der
eröffnung abgesagt wie es weitergeht
wissen sie nicht
in erfurt zittern sie um ihren
weihnachtsmarkt übermorgen soll eröffnet
werden mit bis zu 6000 besuchern dabei
erlaubt thüringens corona verordnung nur
2000 menschen bei veranstaltungen im
freien nun wird getrickst
es steht nirgendwo in der ordnung dass
man statt nur einen weihnachtsmarkt
durchführen darf wir werden dort nicht
einen weihnachtsmarkt eröffnen sondern
drei weihnachtsmärkte öffnen wir haben
den domplatz gehen aufgeteilt in diese
drei bereiche
zwischendurch geben
jetzt wird aufgebaut aber es bleibt
skepsis sind thüringens landesregierung
ein damoklesschwert für die aussteller
so angespannt war keiner weiß genau wie
und was läuft das würde schwierig alles
die situation kindern freude bereiten
will er mit seinem karussell unklar ist
wie lange sich diesmal drehen wird
seit juli warnte die wissenschaft warnte
auch das für gesundheitsschutz
zuständige robert koch institut vor dem
winter es legte berechnungen vor wie
sich bei welcher impfquote die zahlen
entwickeln würden anfang oktober waren
wir längst wieder in einer deutlich
steigenden kurve doch statt auf jene zu
hören die schon in der vergangenheit mit
ihrem warnung und richtig lagen wurden
diskotheken und bars geöffnet
großveranstaltungen zugelassen im
zentrum geschlossen in den schulen nach
den herbstferien die masken abgelegt und
bei manchen war sogar bis vor kurzem
noch von frieden days die rede oder
davon dass eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems nicht zu befürchten
seien dazu trugen auf einige ärzte
funktionäre bei die sich erstaunlich
sorglos äußerten und so sind wir jetzt
wieder dort wo wir schon letzten winter
waren nur noch schlimmer eine
katastrophe mit ansage
dominique löschmeister berichtet
es ist eine fehleinschätzung gewesen von
der geschäftsführenden bundesregierung
wie von der bald neun ampelkoalition die
gefahr einer vierten corona welle
parteiübergreifend unterschätzt
dank des enormen fortschritts bei den
impfungen können wir den pandemischen
ausnahmezustand verlassen gewährten
jetzt einen überschaubaren katalog wenig
eingriffs intensiver maßnahmen zur
verfügung stellen trotzdem schutz aber
eben nicht mehr so tiefe eingriffsrechte
dabei zeigten die korona zahlen zu
beginn des herbstes eine klare richtung
spätestens im oktober war deutschland
wieder im exponentiellen wachstum heute
mehr als 42.000 neuinfektionen wir
werden in eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystem kommen und damit wird
das automatisch sehr restriktive
maßnahmen geben müssen um einfach
wirklich die kontakte zu beschränken und
wirklich diese pandemie wieder in den
griff zu bekommen lange sahen die
verantwortlichen im bund und in den
ländern zu wie sich die situation in den
krankenhäusern immer weiter zuspitzte
die auffrischungsimpfung soll es nun
richten
27 millionen impfungen bis weihnachten
doch reicht das um die vierte welle zu
brechen die durchimpfung der allgemeinen
bevölkerung über 18 jahre bringt im
augenblick für das brechen der welle
wenig aber es ist natürlich trotzdem
außerordentlich wichtig dass erreichen
damit wir im kommenden jahr ruhiger sein
können dass es nicht auch noch eine
fünfte welle gibt die grosse frage lässt
sich ein teil der rund 13 millionen
ungeimpften erwachsenen überzeugen
bisher verharrt die impfquote seit
wochen bei unter 70 prozent vor einer
generellen impfpflicht schrecken die
meisten politiker noch zurück obwohl
fachleute es rechtlich und ethisch für
geboten halten glaube aber schon dass es
doch überwiegen der auffassung ist dass
die freiheit des einzelnen da endet wo
freiheit und gesundheit anderer in
gefahr sind und das ist in diesem
zusammenhang wie ich meine eindeutig der
fall also auch so kann man ganz gut
begründen allgemeine impfpflicht unter
bestimmten umständen ja wichtig ist aber
auch dass wir von impfpflicht leiter
anfang von ihm recht zu reden das heißt
wir müssen ja auch sehen dass die
impfpflicht nicht nur einschränkungen
mit sich bringt sondern menschen vor
einem sehr gefährlichen virus schützt
der lock down als letztes mittel auch in
deutschland bei steigenden zahlen nicht
ausgeschlossen
wir bräuchten eigentlich 30 bis 50
prozent kontakt reduktion dass die dass
diese welle wirklich wieder absinkt und
dafür braucht man letztendlich wirklich
sehr harte restriktionen ähnlich wie wir
das bei einem richtigen lockdown in den
vergangenheiten schon hatten diese
vierte welle war vorhersehbar wie keine
vor ihr und dennoch deutschland steht
viel schlechter da als je zuvor
schlechter als je zuvor dabei wollen wir
mit einem mann sprechen daher genau
davor immer wieder gewarnt hat mit dem
chef des robert-koch-instituts lothar
wieler guten abend herr wieland
guten abend riss linke ja schauen wir
uns die lage gemeinsam an sie sagen ganz
deutschland ist ein einziger großer
ausbruch das heißt sie denken auch nicht
mehr nur regional
ja es ist wichtig ich glaube sind
zunächst einmal zwei dinge wichtig
festzustellen erstens es gibt eine reihe
von krankenhäusern die ihren
versorgungsauftrag nicht mehr in der
nötigen routine und mit den nötigen
kraft wirklich leisten können das müssen
wir einfach konstatieren dass es
regional unterschiedlich aber wir müssen
das konstatieren und wir müssen jetzt
wirklich rhetorisch abrüsten aber wir
müssen operational aufrüsten und das
zweite ist was heißt das wir müssen zwei
dinge tun das eine was wirklich sehr
wichtig ist wir müssen durch kontakt
beschränkungen dafür sorgen dass nicht
noch mehr menschen sich anstecken das
heißt die instanzen steigen und das
zweite was getan werden muss ist eben
wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass wir
so viele menschen wie möglich zum impfen
bewegen und diejenigen die eine
vollständige grundimmunisierung haben
ist das sind die zwei maßnahmen und wir
sollten jetzt wirklich ohne hektik auch
ohne ohne rhetorische auf münsters man
sowas rüsten tun
es wird sehr viel diskutiert mit
teilweise scharfen worten es wird mit
vorwürfen agiert es ist werden
begrifflichkeiten wie tyrannei der
ungeimpften oder sonstigen gearbeitet
wir müssen einfach jetzt die
herausforderung annehmen und mit allen
kräften daran arbeiten das problem
wirklich zu lösen sie gehen aber da
schon davon aus darum nochmal meine
eingangsfrage ein einziger großer
ausbruch dass es nicht im osten und im
süden also bundesländern die bayern
thüringen sachsen bleiben wird sondern
dass sie bei den anderen fällen auch
beobachtet dass dann nach und nach über
das ganze land schwappt
ja also es ist so dass er die inzidenz
das ist ja der der früheste und
wichtigste marker für die
inflationsdynamik dass der nach wie vor
überall ansteigt und je früher wir ihn
bremsen das heißt je geringer die kurve
ist desto stärker ist natürlich der die
wirkung eines eingriffs insofern müssen
wir überall die dynamik prinzen in jedem
bundesland absolut ja ja es gibt ja auch
epidemiologen und in forscher die sagen
wir brauchen eine vollbremsung was würde
das eigentlich bedeuten eine art
bundesweiten lockdown
also es gibt die klare überlegung wenn
man die kontakte sehr stark einschränkt
also soweit es geht dass man dann
natürlich dann den stärksten effekt hat
das sind aber maßnahmen sie wissen das
ja auch dass das zum beispiel teile von
österreich geschieht auch in teilen von
bayern geschieht das hängt wirklich sehr
stark von der regionalen situation aber
wenn man das tut hat mir die stärkste
wirkung bezogen auf das
infektionsgeschehen aber natürlich gibt
es eine reihe von neben aspekten die man
berücksichtigen muss also wichtig ist
auf jeden fall dass jetzt jeder alle
kontakte soweit einschenkt wie es eben
möglich ist und zwar in allen
bundesländern
haben an diesem wochenende rund 100000
gemeldeten neuinfektionen am wochenende
wurde immer weniger gemeldet und auch
generell wird nicht mehr jede infektion
gemeldet man jetzt mal davon ausgeht
dass sind nicht hunderttausenden ich
weiß nicht was denken sie vielleicht in
wahrheit 200.000 wie viele tote bedeutet
dass in zwei drei wochen pro tag und ja
das ist eine sehr gute frage das hängt
natürlich davon ab welche menschen das
sind je mehr geimpfte sich darunter
befinden desto weniger tote je mehr
junge menschen sich darunter befinden
desto weniger tote das hängt wirklich
ganz von der gruppe ab aber eins ist
klar
wir sollten einfach dafür sorge tragen
dass es möglichst wenig menschen sind
denn auch gesunde junge menschen können
ja schwer erkranken warum sollte man
sich dieser krankheit ohne not aussetzen
darum auch nochmal meine wirklich
dringende empfehlung und bitte an alle
dass sie sich impfen lassen man wird
vermutlich die leute die sich bisher
nicht impfen lassen wollten auch mit
appellen nicht mehr erreichen
ja das ist eine große diskussion die
wird natürlich immer stärker geführt
also auf der einen seite wissen wir auch
aus anderen ländern und auch aus studien
die aus anderen bereichen vorliegen wenn
man menschen dazu bewegt sich impfen zu
lassen dadurch dass man zum beispiel
zweig regelungen einführt dann gibt es
durchaus noch einen relevanten teil die
sich dann noch impfen lassen das haben
wir auch in deutschland gesehen
natürlich auch in anderen ländern und
das letzte mittel was er inzwischen auch
immer wieder diskutiert wird ist die
sogenannte impfpflicht und das ist ein
mittel und da bin ich ganz bei der wehr
dass wir alle nicht wollen es ist
wirklich niemand der gerne eine
impfpflicht haben möchte viele viele
studien gibt es dazu viele
wissenschaftler finden das keine gute
lösung aber wenn man alles andere
versucht hat dann sagt die whu dann muss
man auch über eine impfpflicht
nachdenken werden zweig regeln oder 3g
regeln ihrer ansicht nach reichen um
eine bremsung zu machen
also nicht in allen bereichen das ist
ganz klar also da wo sehr hohe instanzen
sind wir haben ja manche bereiche zum
beispiel in bayern oder in sachsen da
reicht das nicht mehr aus und dort
werden ja auch bereits stringentere
maßnahmen durchgeführt das ist bei
residenzen von über 1000 und je nachdem
welche bevölkerungsgruppen davon
betroffen werden auch wirklich die
einzige möglichkeit um das geschehen
wirklich noch so einzudämmen dass die
krankenhäuser nicht immer weiter
überlastet wenn dann ein aspekt der oft
nicht verstanden wird ist das wenn heute
menschen infiziert werden dann sehen wir
die er erst in zwei wochen etwa im
krankenhaus das heißt also das läuft ja
nach also müssen jetzt handeln sie haben
ja schon im juli die entsprechende
zahlen und berechnungen vorgelegt also
das vorher gesehen was sich jetzt
entwickelt hat wie fühlt sich das
eigentlich an wenn man dann immer wieder
warnt aber irgendwie vertrieben taube
ohren predigt oder gegen wände redet
ja das ist nicht erfreulich das ist ganz
klar ich kann das auch nicht immer
verstehen aber ganz klar ist folgendes
was auch immer versäumt wurde das kann
man ja nicht mehr gut machen aber wir
haben ja so viel gelernt wir wissen ja
genau welche mittel helfen wir wissen
dass kontakt reduktion der entscheidende
punkt ist weil das virus jahr zwischen
menschen übertragen wird wir wissen das
alles also lassen sie uns jetzt
gemeinsam diese diese chance nutzen das
jetzt ganz viele verstanden haben dass
wir wirklich vor der medizinischen
notsituationen stehen dass wir jetzt
einfach etwas tun erfreulich ist dass
nicht mal hätte viel früher tun sollen
aber jetzt muss halt wirklich schluss
sein mit laissez faire jetzt muss
implementiert werden regeln überprüft
werden und dann können wir noch sehr
viele menschenleben retten sagt lothar
wieler der chef des robert
koch-instituts ich danke das gespräch
gerne von ihnen ein schöner abend
das interview haben am abend
aufgezeichnet
die pandemie wird jedenfalls noch viel
leid verursachen es soll doch noch viele
tote geben und das sind ja schon so
viele gestorben allein in deutschland
über
99 1000 menschen
vielerorts wird heute am totensonntag
den evangelischen gedenktag für
verstorbene auch der korona toten
besonders gedacht sie haben menschen
zurückgelassen die sie vermissen jeden
tag und damit hadern die einsam ihre
angehörigen sterben mussten an seinen
stern berichtet
jeden tag zündet angelika klomp zu hause
eine kerze an seit fast genau einem jahr
anfang dezember 2020 ist ihr mann
gestorben auf einer cupid
intensivstation
wolfgang klampfer arzt hat sich sehr
wahrscheinlich angesteckt in seiner
praxis im einsatz für seine patienten
jeden tag derselbe weg seit einem jahr
zum grab auf dem friedhof in salzgitter
ich habe tollen freundeskreis mein sohn
hat sich im bombig gekümmert nach in der
ersten zeit wir haben geständig kontakt
das ist alles wunderbar ich darf mich
überhaupt nicht beklagen trotzdem ist es
eine schreckliche einsamkeit so eine
ganz spezielle einsam katima nur kennen
lernt man tatsächlich tatsächlich den
ehepartner verloren hat dem mann geliebt
hat anders kann ich mir das nicht
erklären ist es schrecklich und ich habe
wirklich das gefühl das wird glaube ich
auch nicht besser
einsam alleine ohne abschied von den
lieben sind viele menschen in
deutschland an oder mit dem virus
gestorben mehr als
99.000 bis jetzt einsam alleine viele
angehörige zentrale orte der gemeinsamen
erinnerung gibt es nicht hamburg plant
nun als erstes bundesland eine
gedenkstätte der austausch in der trauer
so wichtig sagen seelsorger gerade für
corona hinterbliebene die neben dem
schmerz auch drängende fragen quellen
wie waren diese letzten stunden denn wir
meinen angehörigen wirklich sagt mir das
pflegeheim alles was ich wissen muss wie
lag da angehörige
wie waren seine letzten worte all das
ist schwer für die korona trauernden
trauer in krisenzeiten in saarbrücken
gab es für einige zeit eine corona
gedenkstätte privat organisiert auf
tafeln wurden die namen sichtbar von
denen die den kampf gegen das virus
verloren haben einfach auch mal
schweigen gemeinsam schweigen und
einfach auch mal fühlen und das hat hier
stattgefunden
das haben ja auch viele angehörige
zurückgemeldet und hier waren auch viele
pflegekräfte die tafeln geschrieben
haben für unsere patienten
2020/2021 die verstorben sind und auch
diese pflegekraft hatten endlich mal ein
ort gehabt und sie mal innehalten
konnten so oft wie möglich innehalten am
grab will angelika klopp hält aber auch
zentrale gedenkstätten für richtig immer
wieder so erzählt sie uns werde sie
überrollt vom trauer schmerz und vom
alleine sein jeden tag seit fast einem
jahr
und jetzt die nachrichten da geht es
zunächst auch noch um die pandemie
bekämpfung 1 es gibt viel kritik an den
plänen des gesundheitsministeriums
bestell obergrenzen für biotec impfstoff
festzulegen der geschäftsführende
gesundheitsminister sparen hat dazu im
interview mit dem zdf sendung berlin
direkt auf eine massive nachfrage in den
vergangenen zwei wochen verwiesen es ist
einfach so dass ich im moment nicht mehr
als zwei bis drei millionen impfdosen
also ab übernächster woche wenn jetzt
die große lieferung war nicht mehr als
zwei bis drei millionen impfdosen
biontech zur verfügung habe das hätten
wir klarer noch kommunizieren müssen
aber wir haben eben mit moderner eine
gute genauso wirksame alternative also
die entscheidende botschaft ist im stoff
ist genug da
in der belgischen hauptstadt brüssel gab
es heute eine großdemonstration gegen
verschärfte corona maßnahmen und 35.000
menschen gingen nach schätzungen der
polizei auf die straße es kam auch zu
gewalttätigen auseinandersetzungen es
gab festnahmen mehrere polizisten wurden
verletzt
im niederländischen den haag gab es in
der vergangenen nacht krawalle danach
zuvor hatte es bereits in rotterdam
schwere ausschreitungen gegeben
bei einem anschlag in der altstadt von
jerusalem sind ein israeli getötet und
drei weitere verletzt worden nach
polizeiangaben hatte ein
palästinensischer angreifer das feuer
eröffnet
er wurde von sicherheitskräften
erschossen der 42 jährige attentäter sei
mitglied der islamistischen
palästinenser organisation hamas gewesen
friedrich merz kandidat für den
cdu-vorsitz sieht seine partei in einer
schweren krise wir haben bei keinem
thema mehr die meinungsführerschaft
nicht einmal in der wirtschaftspolitik
sagte er in der bild am sonntag wie märz
bewerben sich auch noch
kanzleramtsminister brown und der
außenpolitiker röttgen um den cdu
vorsitz
im sudan ist der von teilen der armee
entmachtet regierungschef haben doch
wieder in sein amt als ministerpräsident
zurück gekehrt möglich wurde dies durch
ein abkommen mit den putschisten dass
auch die freilassung aller politischen
gefangenen vorsieht trotz der einigung
gehen die proteste weiter die
demonstranten fordern die absetzung der
für den putsch verantwortlichen militärs
mindestens 40 menschen kamen bei
protesten gegen den putsch in den
letzten wochen ums leben
wo ist schwer diese frage schalte immer
lauter quer über den globus nicht nur
berühmte tennis stars und
sportfunktionäre stellten sie auch
westliche regierungen einschließlich
us-präsident beiden fragten nach ihrem
schicksal die hochkommissarin für
menschenrechte bei den vereinten
nationen forderte von china belege für
ihren verbleib und ihre sicherheit
chinesische tennisspielerinnen die
früher zur internationalen top liga
gehörte war über zwei wochen lang
spurlos verschwunden jetzt ist sie
plötzlich wieder aufgetaucht unter sehr
dubiosen umständen stephanie schöneborn
berichtet aus peking
es sind mehrere videos die zwischen
heute und gestern die tennisspielerin
bombay zeigen sie lächelt hier bei einem
tennisturnier in peking und dort bei
einem abendessen auch in peking das soll
die welt beruhigen denn seit anfang des
monats gilt portugals verschwunden
wie zufällig sagt ihr trainer in diesem
kurzen video morgen ist der zwanzigste
elfter nein der 21 wird er korrigiert es
soll wohl der beweis sein dass es gut
geht und dass die videos von diesem
wochenende sind der chefredakteur der
wichtigsten propaganda zeitung chinas
global times veröffentlicht die
aufnahmen höchstpersönlich und sie
bewirken genau das gegenteil
videos und fotos mit pong spiel wirken
inszeniert die glaubwürdigkeit wird
angezweifelt und der chef des
frauentennis verbands reagiert prompt es
bleibt unklar ob sie frei und in der
lage ist ohne zwang oder einmischung von
aussen entscheidungen zu treffen und
maßnahmen zu ergreifen dieses video
allein ist nicht ausreichend
die ehemalige nummer eins im doppel war
verschwunden weil sie etwas gemacht hat
was in china gefährlich ist in einem
post beschuldigt sie den ehemaligen vize
premier chinas schongau lieh sie sexuell
missbraucht zu haben kurz danach wird
der post gelöscht und mit ihm
verschwindet broadway aus der
öffentlichkeit sportgrößen weltweit
fragen wo ist vom 2 denn frauen die
einen missbrauch öffentlich machen
riskieren hier fiel
die frauen müssen damit rechnen bedroht
zu werden das gesamte umfeld kann
bedroht und unter druck gesetzt werden
wenn frauen solche anschuldigungen in
den sozialen netzwerken veröffentlichen
dann werden ihre online konten
normalerweise blockiert post gar nicht
mehr weitergeleitet werden oder
verschwinden ganz
so wie bei ihr bei einem der wenigen
prozesse wegen sexuellen missbrauchs
wird dieser jungen chinesin massiv
zugesetzt niemand soll ihr statement
hören eine meute älterer frauen wurde
gezielt angeheuert um die klägerin
einzuschüchtern
auch beamte in zivil versuchen
interviews mit ihr zu verhindern
auf dem zettel steht zusammenstehen
niemand darauf diesen mito prozess
öffentlich unterstützen jeder einzelne
wird von der staatspolizei registriert
der in china für rechte kämpft lebt
gefährlich daher auch die sorge um punkt
2 die pessimisten mir wäre beruhigt wenn
ich aus der tennis welt hören würde dass
jemand mit ihr persönlich gesprochen hat
am telefon am besten per facetime und
und mir sagen würde ich habe mit ihr
gesprochen und ihr geht es gut
unwirklich erscheinen veröffentlichte
fotos des tennis stars mit katze und
plüschbären der fall von bombay hat
längst eine politische ebene erreicht
wenige wochen vor beginn der olympischen
winterspiele in peking die usa
frankreich und großbritannien fordern
mehr transparenz
das internationale olympische komitee
berichtet am abend von einem telefonat
von präsident bach mit porsche ein
lebenszeichen fragen bleiben
mit der sportlichen seite des kenners
geht es bereits weiter und zwar mit
einem weiteren erfolg für alexander
zverev hat beim atp finale in turin im
endspiel gegen den russen daniil
medwedew glatt in zwei sätzen gewonnen
der fall hat seinen grandioses
tennisjahr 20 21 alexander zverev spielt
in turin ein finale gegen den russen
medwedew dass zu seinen besten spielen
aller zeiten zählt nicht einen einzigen
breakpunkt gewährte dem russen und dass
er das endspiel mit einem ass beim
zweiten aufschlag beendet sagt viel aus
über seine unerwartet große dominanz im
halbfinale den weltranglisten ersten
djokovic geschlagen und im finale den
weltranglisten zweiten mit wetter zum
jahresabschluss ist alexander zverev der
beste tennisspieler der welt
in der fußball bundesliga hat der sc
freiburg 0 2 gegen eintracht frankfurt
verloren im zweiten sonntagsspiel
trennten sich mainz und der erste fc
köln 1 zu 1 unentschieden
ski rennläuferin lena dürr hat im slalom
heute ihren zweiten podestplatz an
diesem wochenende geholt wie schon
gestern kam sie auf platz drei gewonnen
hat die beiden rennen im finnischen levi
die slowaken petra bülow war vor michela
chiffren aus den usa
bei der formel-1-premiere in katar hat
lewis hamilton gewonnen damit war der
mercedes-pilot die chance auf seinen
achten wm titel rivale max fürst ab und
fuhr von startplatz sieben auf zwei vor
zwei rennen vor saisonschluss die
termiten damit nur acht punkte hinter
dem niederländer ex-weltmeister fernando
alonso belegte für sensationell platz
drei sebastian vettel wurde zehnter und
jetzt zum schluss schauen wir wie immer
sonntags auf die kommende woche
politisch sicher interessanten fürs
kursieren ja schon listen wer im neuen
ampel kabinett angeblich welches
ministerium besetzen sollen dazu wird
man in den nächsten tagen vermutlich
noch einiges hören kamera vier jahren
mit dem wochenausblick
[Musik]
am montag werden die ampel parteien ihre
koalitionsverhandlungen weiter führen
erwartet wird im laufe der woche auch
ein entwurf für einen koalitionsvertrag
und ein möglicher zuschnitt für die
künftige ressortverteilung der fahrplan
sieht vor olaf scholz in der nikolaus
woche zum kanzler zu wählen
angesichts der massiv steigenden corona
zahlen zieht österreich die notbremse ab
montag wird die alpenrepublik in einen
generellen lockdown gehen bis maximal 13
dezember so die regierung die inzidenz
wird inzwischen landesweit bei über
1.000 zudem soll ab februar eine
generelle impfpflicht eingeführt werden
der bundesverband digitale publisher und
zeitungsverleger wird sich am mittwoch
mit der kritik an seinem präsidenten
matthias döpfner befassen döpfner
gleichzeitig auch springer chef hatte in
der pandemie in einer privaten sms ein
vergleich mit dem ddr obrigkeitsstaat
gezogen und journalisten als propaganda
assistenten bezeichnet einzige ausnahme
sei der damalige bild chef julian
reichelt
ebenfalls am mittwoch soll die
unbemannte us unter dort starten im
oktober 2022 soll sie den asteroiden
mond die monrose rahmen um ihn aus
seiner flugbahn zu drängen das
gemeinschaftsprojekt der
raumfahrtbehörde esa und nasa will
szenarien erforschen wie man die erde
vor einem bedrohlichen asteroiden
schützen kann und
noch kurz der ausblick aufs wetter
morgen im norden viel sonne in der mitte
wechselnd bewölkt im süden trüb und
etwas regen den hochlagen etwas schnee
bei lebhaftem nördlichen wind
höchstwerte zwischen 3 und 8 grad und
die weiteren aussichten teils freundlich
teils trüb und nur vereinzelt etwas
regen dienstag 3 bis 10 grad danach
etwas kälter
das war's dann uns an diesem trüben
november sonntag gleich nach uns geht es
mit der krimireihe viana blatt weiter
eine gräfin stirbt im nobel hotel und um
0.30 gibt es dann die nächste heute
express auf wiedersehen
[Musik]